>> Tucker: AT THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC IS FOCUSED ON AWFUL LOT
OF ATTENTION.
THEY HAVE QUIETLY AUTOMATICALLY
UNTHINKINGLY SPENT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS SUPPORTING OVER THE
DECADES AND MOST UP WE FELT GOOD
ABOUT IT.
BUT NOW IT’S TIME TO ASK A VERY
REASONABLE QUESTION THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS IN FACT ASKING.
WHAT ARE WE GETTING FOR THAT
SUPPORT?
CHINA SPENDS LESS THAN HALF AS
MUCH AS WE DO SUPPORTING THE
W.H.O. AND IT’S CLEAR WHAT THEY
GET.
THEY GET A SERVILE GLOBAL
ORGANIZATION THAT’S ABETTING
THEIR RISE TO SUPERPOWER STATUS.
W.H.O. EXCLUDES TAIWAN FOR
MEMBERSHIP SOLELY BECAUSE
BEIJING HAS DEMANDED THAT THEY
DO THAT.
CRUELLY, BY THE WAY.
FROM THE START OF THIS PANDEMIC
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
HAS DONE SHOCKINGLY LITTLE TO
STOP THE VIRUS FROM SPREADING
AROUND THE WORLD.
IN FACT WHEN THE ORGANIZATION
APPEARS IN PUBLIC AT ALL IT
SEEMS TO BE FUNCTIONING PURELY
AS AN OFFSHOOT OF CHINESE STATE
MEDIA.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN THIS CLOSE
TO THREE YEARS AND WAS ELECTED
WITH THE SUPPORT OF CHINA OVER
THE OPPOSITION OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IN LATE JANUARY, TEDROS WAS
GUSHING THAT CHINA HAD CONTAINED
CORONAVIRUS.
IN FACT HE SAID CHINA HAD SET A
STANDARD THAT THE REST OF THE
WORLD OUGHT TO COPY.
>> THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT IS TO
BE CONGRATULATED WITH
EXTRAORDINARY MEASURES IT HAS
TAKEN TO CONTAIN THE OUTBREAK.
CHINA IS ACTUALLY SEARCHING A
NEWSETTING A NEW STANDARD FOR
OUTBREAK RESPONSE AND THAT’S NOT
AN EXAGGERATION.
>> Tucker: ALL HAIL CHINA.
TEDROS WAS SO CONFIDENT THAT
CORONAVIRUS WAS DEFEATED THAT HE
ATTACKED OTHER NATIONS WERE NOT
DARING TO TAKE THE RACE A STEP T
PROTECT THEMSELVES.
HE SAID THAT WOULD HAVE THE
EFFECT EFFECT OF INCREASING’S
FEAR AND STIGMA.
ON FEBRUARY 3RD HE GUSHED ABOUT
THE CHINESE DICTATOR AND
ATTACKED ANY NOTION OF SLOWING
DOWN GLOBAL TRAVEL OR TRADE.
>> I WAS SO IMPRESSED IN MY
MEETING WITH PRESIDENT XI, AND
HIS DETAILED KNOWLEDGE OF THE
OUTBREAK, THERE IS NO REASON FOR
MEASURES THAT UNNECESSARILY
INTERFERE WITH INTERNATIONAL
TRAVEL AND TRADE.
>> Tucker: WELL THAT’S JUST
ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING, STUPID,
IT VIOLATES SCIENCE COMMON
SENSE.
TEDROS WAS COMPLETELY WRONG AND
BECAUSE HE WAS WRONG,
CORONAVIRUS BECAME A GLOBAL
CALAMITY.
THREE WEEKS AGO, AS ONE COUNTRY
ENTERED LOCKDOWN, HE TOLD THE
WORLD YOU SHOULD IMITATE WUHAN.
>> WUHAN REPORTED NEW NEW CASES
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE THE
OUTBREAK STARTED.
WUHAN PROVIDES HOPE FOR THE REST
OF THE WORLD AND EVEN THE MOST
SEVERE SITUATION CAN BE TURNED
AROUND.
>> Tucker: THAT’S ONE OF THE
MOST CORRUPT DISPLAYS I THINK
ANYONE HAS EVER SEEN ON TAPE.
OF COURSE, OTHER COUNTRIES
WANTED TO REDUCE THEIR CASELOAD.
JUST LIKE THE CDC IN THIS
COUNTRY W.H.O. WAS PUSHING THE
ABSURD CLAIM THAT FACE MASKS
SOMEHOW DON’T WORK AND ARE NOT
USEFUL FOR CONTAINING THE
CORONAVIRUS.
CHINA, MEANWHILE, THE COUNTRY
THAT TEDROS NEVER STOPS PRAISING
DID NOT AGREE WITH THAT.
IN FACT THEY WERE HOARDING
MASTS.
YOU START TO WONDER HOW HONEST
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
WAS EVEN GIVING THAT ADVICE.
YOU ALSO HAVE TO WONDER HOWHONES
AGAINST THE USE OF
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE TO FIGHT THE
VIRUS.
>> USING UNTESTED MEDICINES
WITHOUT THE RIGHT EVIDENCE COULD
RAISE FALSE HOPE.
AND EVEN DO MORE HARM THAN GOOD.
>> Tucker: AT THIS POINT IT’S
PRETTY OBVIOUS, THIS GUY IS
TRYING TO HURT PEOPLE.
HE’S INTENTIONALLY TRYING TO
HURT US.
IF HE WANTED AN EFFECTIVE
ANTI-CORONAVIRUS STRATEGY, HE
WOULD JUST DO EVERYTHING THAT
TEDROS TELLS YOU NOT TO.
THAT’S BEEN A PRETTY SOLID
POSITION TO TAKE FOR SOME TIME.
BEFORE HE RAN THE ORGANIZATION,
AND HE WAS THE HEALTH MINISTER
OF ETHIOPIA.
ON THREE SEPARATE OCCASIONS THAT
COUNTRY WAS RAVISHED BY CHOLERA
EPIDEMICS.
HE LIED ABOUT IT AND REFUSED TO
ADMIT IT WAS HAPPENING AND SAID
IT INSTEAD IT WAS JUST AN
OUTBREAK OF ACUTE WATERY
DIARRHEA.
HUNDREDS DIED DURING THAT
OUTBREAK AND IT WAS ONLY
ACCURATELY IDENTIFIED WHEN IT
SPREAD TO NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES.
HE LIED ON BEHALF OF THE
ETHIOPIAN GOVERNMENT WHICH WAS
MORE WORRIED ABOUT TOURISM THAN
PEOPLE SURVIVING THE EPIDEMIC.
WHEN HE TOOK OVER THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION HE VOWED TO
CRACKDOWN ON CORRUPTION AND THAT
HASN’T HAPPENED, EITHER.
THE W.H.O. STILL SPENDS 12 MINI
DOLLARS A YEAR FLYING AT STAFF
AROUND WHICH IS SOMETHING OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS BAND OF THEIR
STAFF FROM DOING.
DOCTORS WITHOUT BORDERS WOULD
NEVER DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
CORRUPTION, DISHONESTY, COVER-UP
COVER-UP, LYING AS PEOPLE DIE?
NO WONDER TEDROS AND CHINA ARE
SUCH PROFOUND ALLIES.
FORTUNATELY PEOPLE ARE WISING UP
TO THIS.
ANDREW CUOMO SAYS WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION SHOULD BE OPEN TO
CRITICISM.
>> WHERE WERE THE WARNING SIGNS?
WHO WAS SUPPOSED TO BLOW THE
WHISTLE?
THE PRESIDENT HAS ASKED THESE
QUESTIONS AND I THINK HE’S
RIGHT.
THE ANSWER IS THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION SHOULD HAVE BEEN
BLOWING THE WHISTLE.
I DON’T KNOW IF THAT’S RIGHT OR
WRONG BUT I KNOW THE QUESTION IS
RIGHT.
>> Tucker: THE QUESTION IS
CERTAINLY RIGHT AND THE ANSWER
IS VERY OBVIOUS.
PEOPLE DIED AS A RESULT THEY
STARTED TO RUN AROUND CALLING
THEMSELVES THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
WHY SHOULD WE SUPPORT CORRUPT
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
THIS?
FUNDING THE W.H.O. HAS ONLY
GIVEN US A HOSTILE, DISHONEST
BUREAUCRACY THAT’S DIRECTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR SPREADING THIS
PANDEMIC.
WE SHOULD GET OUT OF THAT
ORGANIZATION IMMEDIATELY AND